hey ich bin nach amerika geflogen für
eine woche mit einem kumpel und zwar war
es in new york und dann drei tage noch
in der wir waren auf jeden fall eine
woche weg und ich haben eigentlich
gesagt es steht keine kamera mit weil
das urlaub war und wie das halt alles
dinge die sehr genießen wollten und ich
halte nicht die ganze dieses gefühl
haben wollte dass ich unbedingt die
kamera dabei haben muss und alles
blocken und festhalten musste gegen hier
habe ich aber trotzdem so eine kleine
kompaktkamera mitgenommen und die
aufnahmen sind vielleicht nicht die
allerbesten und ceo so spontane stumpfe
aufnahmen wie beispielsweise das soll
das kontroll und bord und kann also
sagen ich hab nur so ein paar stumpfe
bescheuerte aufnahmen gemacht aber ich
dachte mir wieder von euch hatten ihr
halb geschrieben so von wegen luca
bekommen wir noch etwas zu sehen von
einer amerikareise deswegen die sachen
die ich gefilmt habe packe ich euch
jetzt einfach mal hier in den block
zusammen also es ist jetzt kein toller
blog es ist einer der schlimmsten blogs
die wahrscheinliche gesehen haben
ich verstehe es gar nicht läuft das ding
jetzt schon das ist hoch da sind
hochhäuser und
wir wollten einen trade center gehen
aber da ist er tatsächlich da stehen wir
waren nicht die einzigen die sich das
gedacht haben
so viele komische menschen von alle sind
komisch baustelle
fertig scheiße
schön schön schön
wir sind da und wir müssen
ich werde nicht mehr es reicht einfach
überall nach kompletten durchfall ich
dagegen immer mein auto fährt richtig
aber wenn ich dann so was
bisher aufträge im film von meinen
professional blogs in new york immer
noch und man ist ein bisschen platz wo
mein gott man kann das ist es her da ist
eine brücke an stellen streichen davon
ist jetzt kommt die sonne ist weg
ich wollte eigentlich voll kultfilm weil
da vorne ist ist so die skyline und als
eine brücke lassen ihre kinder ja
einfach direkt an den wellen spielen und
das als deutsch vol gefährlich aber da
vorne ist halt richtig schön wieder ich
glaube alles was ich im blog ist immer
schön nach vorne haben wir die sonne die
spiegelt sich so wundervoller im wasser
und da hinten ist und jetzt kenter
wieder sonne gegenwart lang die heiraten
ich werde nicht mehr sondern und
juni
ich sitze dann auch immer richtig lieben
die leute hier so miteinander klar
frankfurt aber eigentlich sind wir noch
tatsächlich alles sehr hoch wir sind
tatsächlich sehr hoch was ist das da
dieses kind über holz über
da hinten rein und man kann wirklich
tatsächlich ist nach deutschland gucken
das schon machen
da ich noch nicht genug kurz gedacht wir
gehen noch aufs rockefeller center und
schauen quasi hier nochmal 'ran taten
schwere viel scheiße bestehende vorne
überhaupt soll kleiner so ein ding von
unten nach oben hoch gebaut und sieht
einfach grottig scheiße aus und ist es
überhaupt kein plan
was man nach
dank
wir sind angekommen
alles sehr schön aus mit palmen und
sonne schaut euch einfach das anhalter
und wir haben da hinten die sonne machen
das ist alles hier kommt auch einfach
überall musik aus bogen raus was einfach
alles immer viele schöne dinge nicht
schön es ist jetzt abend gewonnen es
immer noch wunderschön das ist halt
einfach so man hat mir vorne so diese
komischen teile wieder hoch schießen wir
haben hier vorne sorgt natur aber so
günstig angelegt aber sieht einfach aus
wie im märchen
gemeldet dort schwimmt noch ein paar
zentimeter
guten morgen sls ist gerade sieben uhr
740 der plan ist dass wir trainieren
gehen
duschen danach 72 ein video aufnehmen
dann strand danach dann wieder ins hotel
fertig machen für die premiere die dann
ist die filmpremiere danach zur
aftershowparty da mal wieder hierhin und
damit an
wir sind im pool es ist einfach ultra
waren es ist schönes wetter da hinten
corning your life goes on the children
under the age of fortin
ach du heilige scheiße ich dafür bin ich
rein wir laufen jetzt gerade 72 haben
uns frisch gemacht hier schön kurze hose
und jetzt ist hier tatsächlich schaffen
eine baustelle alter ich weiß wie du
meinst franziskus nice aber ich finde
dass allein schon schön ich mal von
ihnen zusammen cisco als zwei mal zornig
splatter und es ist angenehm oder
chaotisch ablaufen und wir sind gerade
bei studio 71 amerika angekommen und dir
aus nicht meine lieben freunde ist auf
jeden fall relativ stattlich da hinten
sieht man dass hollywood sein da die
ganzen berge dahin ist sogar die steven
sind ja gerade halt irgendwie im zehnten
stock und können von hier ganz nahe zu
überschauen überall taucht schon natur
durch alles bekommen wir sitzen jetzt
hier und trinken cola und werden dann
gleich ein video aufnehmen es gerade
unglaublich cool so wir sind in der
schön das wetter wir haben nicht einmal
die aus
wir sind am ende angekommen ich glaube
ihr verstand auch ich wollten mich ist
wir sind zurück kommt
man muss fertig gemacht sind jetzt hier
downtown und werden jetzt gleichauf
das ist okay was fällt diesem gebäude
ein das ist einfach noch im bau ist
vorbei an geschaut
jetzt war
wenn ich wohl
meyer
mir
guten morgen herr wir haben ein bisschen
ausgeschlafen weil wir gestern noch auf
der premiere waren
ich habe mir gar nicht ausgeschafft wir
müssen auf jeden fall um 12 uhr
auschecken das heißt wir werden jetzt
frühstücken gehen sachen zusammenpacken
und dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich nach
dem check out werden wir noch am pool
und dann die sonne und wir werden uns
dann da kleine planänderungen sind jetzt
doch wieder bei studios tevatron in los
angeles und ich gestern bei der premiere
nicht allzu viel gefilmt habe von diesem
film dass das hängt über all das sind so
fette poster von dem film natural born
killers erst wahlkreis der grund warum
wir alle waren das habe ich in diesem
blog gericht behandelt weil die reise
eigentlich über new york in sollte das
habe ich auch vor dem wir die ganze zeit
gesagt allerdings um mir spontan
eingeladen zu ihrer premiere und das
quasi so bekommen und das ist ultra cool
deswegen wollte ich denn jetzt einmal
irgendwas zurückgeben und ja das ist das
ist der film ihr könnt mal definitiv in
die beschreibung schauen und findet ihr
einen link dazu dieser link ist ein
itunes link da könnt ihr den film kaufen
dann ansehen et cetera da geht es um
prank sum alles möglich und echt krasse
sachen check das auf jeden fall mal aus
es in der infobox das ist der film mit
yvonne frank saß ich zeige euch noch mal
ganz kurz die aussicht hier alter ist
das neues ich hab mir die soweit geguckt
es wird lecker brief beschreibt wir
legen jetzt am pool
das war heftig gut wir sind jetzt aber
auch schon am flughafen l und geben
jetzt quasi unsere koffer ab weil wir
jetzt wieder nach new york fliegen
wir sind zurück in unserem hotelzimmer
new york und werden halt ein paar
stunden weiter fliegen nach frankfurt
zurück nach deutschland deswegen per
märz erst mal eine runde
hi
checker raum 12 es ist gerade 13 04 und
dem auto liegt zumal weil wir fast
nichts vorwerfen aber wollten noch ein
bisschen shoppen gehen weil wir noch
zeit da man sich noch so
und beim
shoppen wieder
wir sind gerade in der mall nicht
angeschnallt ist und ich finde dich mit
und kaum noch schlafen
gerade hier noch von anderer art mit
eiern und deswegen
wieder fiel genau in einer stunde und
gemeinsam
hallo alle miteinander ich bin wieder zu
hause angekommen ist jetzt wie spät ist
es gerade ist gerade für den verein
diese claudia gekommen total fertig
irgendwie in den letzten beiden nächten
zusammen drei bis vier stunden
geschlafen das war es von der new york
reise ich hoffe euch hat dieser trashig
blog gefallen ich hab mir mal
angekündigt dass sich der die blogs
machen werde so wenn ich sie machen
werde werden sie nicht so sein wie ich
sie jetzt gemacht habe das sollte jetzt
wirklich mehr so ich habe gesagt ich
habe versucht so wir sind sieben tage
weg und ich wollte jeden tag nur das
wichtigste einfallen damit der blog ich
nachher 20 minuten sondern jetzt er sei
fünf minuten
vielleicht ist auch 20 minuten angreifen
werde es eine gefahr da würden wir ich
mich über eine bewertung von und dann ja
und jetzt bin ich quasi wieder hier zu
hause
ich hatte diese kamera dabei und haben
wirklich einfach nur zwischendurch wo
ich mir dachte okay das könnte man
witzig filmen oder hey da könnte ich
würd sich darauf reagieren oder hell das
sieht cool aus da habe ich dann quasi
aber die kamera rausgeholt und habe
darauf geheilt und habe das gefilmt und
festgehalten und das wollte halt einfach
irgendwie zusammen packen damit ich
diese datei nicht einfach löschen
wenn euch das ganze vielleicht trotzdem
gefallen da will ich mich über eine
bewertung freundes ist ein echter so ein
stumpfes spontanes video einfach mal das
ziel zusammen gepackt und dann sehen wir
uns
ich wollte nach unten verschwinden aber
jetzt keinen platz